i have 1 000 random minecraft players
and 10 of the biggest youtubers on the
platform and whichever one of you
survives the longest i'll give your mom
this 30 000 tv behind me that's a lot of
cheddar and with that begin the
challenge
go go go go go let's go to the ship
we'll get up and like as far as we kill
people they have to get all the way back
here
i was just seeing you following me like
oh god release the hunters
oh actually no i see them look at all
their names ship oh i see all the names
through the walls oh they're coming out
the boat they're coming up oh we're
screwed
[Music]
oh my god oh my god help help there's
hundreds oh my gosh guys you guys are
being sworn recipes
don't just look at me where are you guys
please help chandler you have literally
200 people chasing you somebody help me
uh guys people are coming up people are
literally coming up put the bombs in the
hole put the bombs in the hole
wait are you guys spawn camping my mom
wants that tave dude if some cobblestone
popped up here it'd make your life
harder no no no no no no stay back there
yeah wait dude they're flying up the
stairs what are you guys gonna do
there's so many of them
sorry guys i love you i left i'm making
friends with this frog he'll help me
okay god they're fuel coming everywhere
what do we do fight fight we'll defend
our land oh my god okay so you guys are
just camping the shipping containers
well it's not really working screw it
i'm going over they're all dying
by protection
i'm out of here
i'm trapped in a tree and there's
hundreds of people below me somehow my
gosh i have to hold lobby on me bro
oh they beat me underneath no way
that's not even where there's three
people i need help oh god i don't know
where you are i'm down on the floor
george come down here come down here
come down here look look i've almost
lost a whole row of hearts i'm literally
going to you guys right now i got you
guys how can i get back on the ship like
i'm in the sea
oh fundy's up there dying oh and stop me
go after tommy there's somebody right
down there get tommy get tommy instead
yes
yes see you idiots i'm out of here
oh victory
i'm jumping into the water this is it
i'm back i'm back at full health
i threw my sword
oh god i'm being demolished up the
stairs i am so dead buddy your hearts
are getting low i am not okay hey jimmy
is that a nord vpn building on the map
yeah it's literally the best vpn company
on the planet tell me more nor vpn is
super easy to use and has servers all
across the world wait jimmy does that
mean i can watch movies and anime in
australia that's right chris you can
have instant secured access to the full
catalogs of hundreds of streaming sites
worldwide and watch this
i'm now in australia g'day good eye i'm
upside down jimmy change it back nordvpn
also offers double protection with your
ip it's true jimmy i'm trying to find
your ip right now and i can't head to
nordvpn.com to get a two year plan with
one month free at a massive discount and
best of all it has a 30 day risk free
money back guarantee that's
nordvpn.comgaming or just click the link
in the description to get your ginormous
discount ginormous now you should
probably run away oh yeah i don't know
what to do i'm so low they're better
than me i'm not good at minecraft i get
it chris and fundy on the verge of death
this is getting intense the fact that
i'm still alive after all of this is
incredible
all right chris you died yeah i did
i don't know
wait tommy are you on the boat yes i see
them dude tommy look i'm down here if
you can get up the ladder techno and you
can jitter click up here with me then
we've won like no one will get up i'm
getting knocked at the bottom there's no
chance i can get up this ladder
i'm out i'm escaping guys i'm coming to
the boat tommy quick jump down and save
me i'm losing hearts at a rapid rate
i'll lead them away tommy don't worry
about me
away from me
bro
get away from me no i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die wait no oh come on i've only
got five hearts no why'd you do that no
nolan died nolan i hardly know her oh
oh
i want to talk about your death nolan
but fundy's about to die so screw you
wait i'm escaping i'm so escaping this
oh my god
am i alive
i just lost two rows of heart doing that
bundy don't give up think of your mom
no
bundy died fundy i hardly know her chris
nolan and fundy all hate their mom i
don't hate my mom gentlemen the border
is currently shrinking right now good
luck oh no not right now the water was
my strategy oh come on dream what's 10
times 10. uh you didn't answer quick
enough shrinking again no dream good
luck everybody dude we have to go we
have to move all the board to the border
run run run run
dream dream i see you we're so dead
dream you and i i'm gonna die i'm gonna
diet
dream come back no i'm sorry techno i'm
not coming back wait i'm just gonna die
to the boulder then get out of the
border
oh i got stuck in a hole there's no way
i don't die it's over uh subscribe to
laser beam subscribe
no
laser beam has bit the dust my mom is
unsubscribing from mr beast
guys this is the end for me holy crap
tech goes down to nine hearts please
more items anything if you tell people
to subscribe subscribe
there you go
there are so many people following
septum hey sapnabe
jimmy help me help me jimmy i will only
give you a supply crate if you upload
twice in december okay i will i will i
will like well i promise i'm trusting
you sapnam
i got an electro wait i need something
carl i'll give you a supply drop if you
give me your mom's number it is
there you go
wait how am i supposed to get that in
two seconds i'm gonna close the border
jimmy wait don't please all right the
border's been closed oh my god the
border is so close the border needs to
stop sure jimmy i'm i'm out i'm out now
you got it you got it i believe in you
carl i'm 100 out carl's down to 16
hearts my care package is outside of the
border jimmy you don't need a care
package if you're just gonna die could
you just move me somewhere i gotta be
fair fear jimmy i'm gonna die
you're out three yards carl dig deep
think of your mom die go die
will he get cornered
carl let's get him pinned well he died
oh half a heart
dang it dang it dang it let's find out
who will disappoint their mom next
they found me they found me they found
me dream dream i see you get away from
me there's like a million idiots chasing
me oh
no i'm losing so you guys all seem to be
struggling and i have good news oh yeah
i'm gonna shrink the zone again in a
minute oh no jimmy why why why george
save me no i need you to die i want to
win the tv oh chill they're so close to
dying chandler no oh i got three hearts
chandler no i'm dead
no
no
no
i hardly know her there's now five
people competing for their moms we need
to meet up together and work together
it's our only chance i'm good with that
uh go ahead and meet up because the
zone's gonna be shrinking quick oh god
the zone is coming in so quick it's
coming in so quick we're cutting off 50
of the playing field oh my god there's
so many players confined to this one
spot you guys have to start dying soon
how are you guys still alive guys i'm
dropping supply drops for days there is
so much lag i can't see anything yeah
i'm lagging i'm lagging i'm lagging so
hard i gotta get to the supply drops
i got all the supply drops i have like
seven elytras set up [ __ ] set up
yeah
wait i bet savannah's hiding somewhere
he is jimmy jimmy i pearled here
legitimately i took a risk by going to
the middle i deserve the rewards yeah
sure you can tell yourself that but i'm
giving them a way to get to you jimmy
you've ruined me
subscribe to mr beast to eat beast
burger please going to have to stop no
more helps you delve sees you're on your
own i'm going to die i'm going to die
i'm going to die tommy in it no
no i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead 100 i'm dead i'm dead i died no
no dream
techno sapnap and george are all that
remains one of your moms is getting a 30
000 tv the other two are watching right
now and sad dude i don't think we're
beating sap nap son i'll just die you
die george carl you're in charge of
making sure sapnap can always be
attacked oh i'd love to do that
carl stop carl please remember our love
this is so hard i'm so low oh he's about
to die i have two hours i'm dead no no
george answer this math question i'll
give you a supply crate what's 13 times
13 hey siri what's 13 times 13 30
390 390. okay here's the supply drop 319
what why would you reward that wait
that's not even the right answer where's
the supply chain no
no please let me in let me in
i'm stealing his supplies
stop george how are you not dead you
have one heart no some spamming
oh george just died
i think this is the end for tech no
blade techno please we can live forever
i'd like that very much you're getting
me so emotional that i want to just
remove all the lightrooms from the
server no that's all i have server
remove elytras oh no no tag everybody is
so low someone half a hurt
no
tag don't die gotten the best
so i got the 30 000 tv here can you tell
me your address yes it's